Hello, everyone.
I would say Merry Christmas, but I'm not
sure I can say those words because I've
been hearing that Christmas is pagan.
This leads to an interesting question.
What's more pagan, Christmas or the
Kaaba?
Is one more pagan than the other? That's
what we're here to discuss, and I'm here
with Mike Jones of Inspiring Philosophy.
Mike, we've got Christmas,
Santa Claus, we're talking elves, we're
talking reindeer, we're talking stuff
going on up at the North Pole, bringing
presents, we're talking Christmas trees,
people bowing down just to get under the
Christmas tree to get their reward from
their pagan tree.
What's going on with all of this? How is
this not pagan? Yeah, none of this is
pagan. Let's start with the date. Uh it
seems as though early Christians
believed that Jesus was going to die on
the same day he was conceived. They
believed he died on March 25th. So, that
means he was also conceived on that day
in their minds. So, you just count
forward nine nine months, you get
December 25th. That's where the date
comes from.
No evidence of a pagan festival on that
date prior to the rise of Christianity
under Constantine. So, people will say
Saturnalia was a Roman holiday. That was
on December 17th, never lasted to
December 25th, according to order early
sources like Macrobius and others. Some
will say there was a sun holiday called
Sol Invictus on December 25th. No
evidence for that, either. Uh it seems
as though the earliest source that
mentions Sol Invictus on that date was
uh
calendar of Filocalus, which dates to
354 AD, which is post-Constantine.
So, I've argued that it's probably more
likely that after the rise and
prominence of Christianity, pagans
started using that date to celebrate
pagan worship to compete with the rise
of Christianity and their use of
December 25th or that date for
Christmas. You mentioned Christmas
trees. They don't go back to paganism,
either. The earliest source that
mentions them is uh
comes from 1419
in modern in modern-day Germany.
Uh and this this is in
Burn Brunner's book, Inventing the
Christmas Tree.
And either they came from maypoles,
which was again another European folk
tradition, or they came from the use of
paradise trees. Because on December
24th, they would celebrate the feast day
of Adam and Eve with an Adam and Eve
play. And they would decorate a pine
tree with apples to help uh
celebrate the the day and to perform the
play.
So,
a lot of scholars think the paradise
tree in those clearly very Christian
plays morphed into the Christmas trees.
Use of Santa Claus clearly comes from
Saint Nicholas.
Uh he was a Catholic saint, but in about
the early 1800s in New York, a lot of
Dutch immigrants uh wanted to morph him
into a more a Christmas figure. So, they
uh rebranded him to look more like the
tradi- they rebranded him to look in the
traditional attire of a Dutchman from
that time, which is why he's in a big
red suit. And then it started to take
off because of writers like Clement
Moore, Thomas Thomas Nash. So, that's
also Christian in origin. It was just
morphed through the imagination of Dutch
immigrants in New York, and it just
slowly evolved into the Santa Claus
traditions we have today. I've gone
through every prominent Christian Excuse
me, I've gone through every prominent
Christmas tradition
uh in a video called The Top 10
Christmas Traditions and Their Origin. I
can find no evidence any of them go back
to paganism, whether it's stockings,
mistletoe, reindeer, Yule logs, even. No
evidence these go back to paganism. So,
at the end of the day,
Christmas is entirely Christian in
origin with some European folk
traditions added in.
Well,
I guess I was wrong. Christmas doesn't
sound pagan at all, and that's good news
because there's still time to buy
Christmas presents. But you don't need
to wait until the last minute running
from store to store like a maniac. Artza
has you covered. Artza has launched
their brand new Christmas box called
Nativity Night, and you definitely want
this for a friend or loved one. Each
item in your Artza box is handmade by
local artisans and small family
businesses in places like Nazareth and
Jerusalem and Bethlehem. So, when you
sign up with Artza, you're blessing and
supporting these artisans and families
while bringing the land of the Bible
right into your home or someone else's
home.
Inside, there's an awesome hand-painted
ceramic plate depicting the night of the
nativity, delicious foods and spices, a
hand-carved olive wood nativity ornament
from Bethlehem, and other handcrafted
treasures that bring the story of
Christmas to life. So, help a friend or
loved one experience Christmas this year
with a box of gifts straight from the
land where Jesus walked. They're only
selling this box for a few more days,
and it's almost sold out. Plus, they
just increased our discount. You'll get
15% off with the promo code Dazzle. So,
this is the perfect gift to celebrate
Christmas and share the beauty of the
Holy Land with your loved ones. Click
the link and sign up today.
Now, back
to Christmas versus the Kaaba.
We thought Christmas was pagan, but it
turned out not to be pagan. Maybe we
think the Kaaba is pagan, but it's
actually not. What are your thoughts?
Well, I've been told by Muslims that
this was built by Abraham. Uh
even though it's not mentioned in
Genesis. So, how could it be pagan if it
was built by a strict monotheist?
Yeah, it's interesting how Islam got a
lot of its beliefs. When you
look at what Islam teaches, it's as if
Muhammad just took almost everything
that was popular around him at his time
in 7th century Arabia and rolled it up
into a big ball. You've got various
elements of Jewish monotheism and
teachings from the Talmud, they end up
in the Quran. You've got Christians and
even heretical Christians with some
weird sources, and these stories end up
in the Quran. And then you have the
various
pagan practices and beliefs and so on,
they end up as part of Islam. So, it
shouldn't be surprising when we check
out their hajj rituals in the Kaaba and
we find this saturated in paganism
because the Kaaba
was a site of pagan worship. And this
isn't according to me, this is according
to Muslim sources.
Sahih Bukhari, 2478.
Narrated Abdullah ibn Masud, "The
prophet entered Mecca, and at that time,
there were 360 idols around the Kaaba.
He started stabbing the idols with a
stick he had in his hand and reciting,
'And say truth, i.e. Islamic monotheism
or this Quran or jihad against
polytheists, has come, and battle,
falsehood, i.e. Satan or polytheism, has
vanished.'"
This is when Muhammad took control of
the Kaaba. But think about this, why
would they want to take control of a
site that was a center of pagan worship?
Why would you want a pagan shrine as
your center of worship, especially when
we know that before they started facing
the Kaaba for their worship, they were
facing the temple in Jerusalem. They're
facing the temple in Jerusalem. That was
their qibla before the Kaaba became
their qibla. So, they understood that
Jews are the monotheists, and their site
is in Jerusalem, so Muslims would pray
facing Jerusalem, too, to copy the Jews.
Interestingly, Muhammad thought that the
Jews were going to accept him as a
prophet. They rejected him as an obvious
false prophet, and that's when Allah
suddenly changed his mind about
where Muslims were supposed to face
when they pray. And here's what we find
in Surah 2, verse 144 of the Quran.
Allah says, "We see the turning of thy
face for guidance to the heavens. Now
shall we turn thee to a qibla that shall
please thee." Talking to Muhammad.
"Turn then thy face in the direction of
the sacred mosque. Wherever ye are, turn
your faces in that direction. The people
of the book know well that this is the
truth from their Lord, nor is God
unmindful of what they do."
So, Allah's goal in changing the qibla
from Jerusalem to Mecca was to please
Muhammad. It's weird how so many things
in this religion are just Allah trying
to please Muhammad. But think about
this, why would changing from facing
Jerusalem to facing a pagan center of
worship be pleasing to Muhammad?
Well, two main reasons. One, the Jews
rejected him, and so, "Haha, I'm not
going to face Jerusalem anymore. That'll
teach you guys."
And second,
these guys all grew up, the pagans, the
polytheists, grew up
with the Kaaba as their center of
worship. So, it was very normal to them.
This was normal to them. It just felt
right. But you have an issue. How can
you justify? How can you make sense of
the idea
of changing your direction of prayer
from Jerusalem to a pagan center of
worship? How does that work?
Well, just a little earlier in Surah 2,
verse 127, Allah declared that the Kaaba
was built by Abraham and Ishmael. Now,
that's interesting. If it was built by
Abraham and Ishmael, and if the Muslims
knew this, why were they facing
Jerusalem? They've got a shrine built by
Abraham and Ishmael right there. Why
weren't they facing that all along? It
really seems like Muhammad's just
inventing this as he goes along. But
what evidence do we have that the Kaaba
was built by Abraham and Ishmael? Are
you aware of any? I am not aware of any
evidence, no. The only evidence is
Muhammad said it. And that's good enough
for Muslims usually.
It can't be good enough for us because
we know this guy had absolutely no clue
what he was talking about on various
issues. Here's an example.
Sahih al-Bukhari 3366.
Narrated Abu Dhar. I said, "Oh Allah's
messenger, which mosque was first built
on the surface of the earth?" He said,
"Al-Masjid al-Haram at Mecca."
I said, "Which was built next?" He
replied, "Al-Masjid al-Aqsa at
Jerusalem." I said, "What was the period
of construction between the two?" He
said, "40 years."
Are you catching this?
According to Muhammad, there was a
40-year gap between the construction of
the Kaaba and the temple in Jerusalem.
Now, this is interesting because
according to them,
the Kaaba is built by Abraham and
Ishmael, the temple in Jerusalem was
built by Solomon in the 10th century BC,
more than a thousand years before
Abraham. According to Muhammad, Abraham
and Solomon are 40 years apart.
Okay, you're already dealing with
someone who has absolutely no clue what
he's talking about. So, why should we
believe this guy when he says anything?
And if Muhammad doesn't actually know
his history and he's getting things
wrong and making things up as he goes
along, well, guess what? Apart from his
word, we have no evidence at all that
the Kaaba was ever associated with
Abraham and Ishmael.
And yet we have Muslims today that take
the pilgrimage there because they think
it's what Muhammad said it is.
Um they walk circles around the Kaaba.
By the way, do you know why Muslims walk
seven times around the Kaaba?
They don't either.
But we know why the pagans walked seven
times around the Kaaba. It was to honor
the seven planetary deities. They
noticed that there were seven heavenly
bodies that they were aware of that
moved differently from the stars. They
were aware of the sun, the moon,
Mercury, Venus, Mars, Jupiter, and
Saturn. And they associated each of
those heavenly bodies with a different
pagan god. And to honor each of these
pagan gods, they walked circles around
the Kaaba like these bodies circled the
earth. That's why they did it. Muslims
kept the same practice,
but they don't realize where it comes
from. They just keep doing the same
things
based on what they're taught.
So, this is as pagan as paganism gets,
and now it's one of the five pillars of
Islam. Well, let me guess. If it looks
like paganism, walks like paganism, and
talks like paganism,
it must be pure monotheism in disguise.
You're exactly right, Mike. And when
Muslims visit the Kaaba, they do
everything they can to kiss the black
stone, which is interesting because
stone worship was a standard feature in
pagan Arabia. As we read in Sahih
al-Bukhari 4376,
narrated Abu Raja al-Utaridi, "We used
to worship stones, and when we found a
better stone than the first one, we
would throw the first one and take the
latter. But if we could not get a stone,
then we would collect some earth, i.e.
soil, and then bring a sheep and milk
that sheep over it and perform the
tawaf, that's what Muslims do today,
around it."
What did the pagans worship? A stone.
And when they found a better stone, they
would replace that stone with the new
stone and worship the new stone. Where
does this end? When you find the best
stone. Once you have the best stone to
worship, then you just worship that
stone. And so, they end up with the
black stone of Mecca. And I mean, it's
like they're saying, "Hey, we want to do
everything that the pagans are doing,
but somehow it's just not It's not pagan
when we do it."
Interesting stuff. And what's amazing is
that Muhammad's companions would even
recognize that this really seems pagan,
and we got a problem with this, but
since we saw Muhammad doing it, we have
to do it, too. In Sahih al-Bukhari 1597,
we read,
narrated Abis bin Rabia, "Umar came near
the black stone and kissed it and said,
'No doubt, I know that you are a stone
and can neither harm anyone nor benefit
anyone. Had I not seen Allah's messenger
kissing you, I would not have kissed
you.'"
This is Umar, the second of the rightly
guided caliphs, saying he knows he
shouldn't be kissing a pagan idol like
the black stone, but he had to do it
just because Muhammad said. And there's
more. Muslims run between the hills of
Safa and Marwah. But we know the pagans
ran between these two hills as well
because
they had two pagan idols there.
Yusuf Ali comments on Surah 2:158 of the
Quran,
"The virtue of patient perseverance in
faith leads to the mention of two
symbolic monuments of that virtue. These
are the two hills of Safa and Marwah,
now absorbed in the city of Mecca and
close to the well of Zamzam. Here,
according to tradition, the lady Hagar,
mother of the infant Ishmael, prayed for
water in the parched desert. And in her
eager quest round these hills, she found
her prayer answered and saw the Zamzam
spring. Unfortunately, the pagan Arabs
had placed a male and a female idol
there, and their gross and superstitious
rites caused offense to the early
Muslims."
So, we know and they knew that this was
a pagan ritual performed by pagans for
their idols.
What evidence do we have that this had
anything to do with Hagar and Ishmael?
Absolutely none. All we have is Muhammad
said it. But keep in mind, Muhammad is
the same guy who thought that Abraham
and Solomon lived 40 years apart. He
apparently makes things up as he goes
along to take elements of paganism and
bring them into his religion by saying,
"Oh, this was from Abraham. This was
from Hagar." Based only on his word, and
he had no clue what he was talking
about.
But interestingly, we know that even
Muhammad's companions understood that
this is just a pagan practice.
Sahih al-Bukhari 3847.
Narrated Ibn Abbas, "To run along the
valley between two green pillars of
As-Safa and Al-Marwah mountains was not
Sunnah,
but the people in the pre-Islamic period
of ignorance used to run along it and
used to say, 'We do not cross this rain
stream except running in great haste.'"
Now, this is devastating to Islam
because Ibn Abbas says that this
practice was just a pagan practice. It
wasn't part of the Sunnah of Muhammad.
Notice the commentary at the bottom.
"This statement of Ibn Abbas is wrong as
most of the religious scholars consider
it as Sunnah of the prophet." Most of
the religious scholars, in order to
rescue Islam, have to throw Ibn Abbas
under the bus. This is getting
ridiculous.
Sahih al-Bukhari 4496. Narrated Asim bin
Sulaiman, "I asked Anas bin Malik about
As-Safa and Al-Marwah. Anas replied, 'We
used to consider going around them a
custom of the pre-Islamic period of
ignorance. So, when Islam came, we gave
up going around them.'"
Wait a minute. They didn't know about
Hagar and Ishmael?
"Then Allah revealed, 'Verily, As-Safa
and Al-Marwah, two mountains at Mecca,
are of the symbols of Allah. So, it is
not a sin on him
who performs Hajj or Umrah pilgrimage of
the house, the Kaaba, at Mecca.'"
So, here again, the early Muslims
understood that this was a pagan
practice. They said they stopped doing
it when they became Muslims, and then
Muhammad would bring it back and explain
that it has some connection to
people who aren't pagans. This is what
we find over and over and over again. We
find a pagan practice, Muhammad makes
something up to bring the pagan practice
into Islam. So, what have we learned
here? Well, Christmas
sounds pagan to a lot of people, talking
about Santa Claus and Christmas trees.
Turns out, we know where these things
came from, and these do not have pagan
origins. In Islam,
the Kaaba, the black stone, running back
and forth between the hills of Safa and
Marwah, all of these have a pagan
origin, and Muhammad brings it into his
religion anyway,
wraps it up and pretends it's pure
monotheism.
So, Christmas, not pagan. Kaaba,
100%
pagan.
Be sure to check out Mike's videos on
Christmas for more.
>> [music]
[music]